ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States
oh hello hello thank you very much thank
you
thank you very much everybody please
have a seat thank you hello Pittsburgh
it is good to be back Thank You senator
Casey and mayor Ravenstahl and County
Executive Dan Onorato state auditor Jack
war wagon ER and all of you for having
me back here at carnegie-mellon it is
good to be here and it seems like every
time I'm here I learn something so for
those of you who are thinking about
Carnegie Mellon it's it's a terrific
place and and you guys are doing just
great work I just met with folks from
some cutting edge companies and saw some
of their inventions here in your
national robotics engineering center but
that's not the only reason I'm here you
might not know this but one of my
responsibilities as commander-in-chief
is to keep an eye on robots
and I'm pleased to report that the
robots you manufacture here seem
peaceful at least for now this is a city
that knows something about manufacturing
for generations of Americans it was the
ticket to a middle-class life here and
across America's industrial heartland
millions clocked in each day at
foundries on assembly lines to make
things and the stuff we make steel cars
planes was the stuff that made America
what it is the jobs were good they paid
enough don't a home to raise kids send
them to college to retire there were
jobs that told us something more
important than just how much money we
made what was in our paycheck these jobs
also told us that we were meeting our
responsibilities to our family and to
our neighborhoods and building our
communities and building our country but
for better and worse our generation has
been pounded by wave after wave of
profound economic change revolutions in
technology have transformed the way we
live and the way we work businesses and
industries can relocate anywhere in the
world anywhere that there are skilled
workers anywhere but there is an
internet connection
and companies have learned to become
more efficient with fewer employees in
Pittsburgh you know this as well as
anybody steel mills that once needed a
thousand workers now do the same work
with a hundred and while these changes
have resulted in great wealth for some
Americans
have drastically increased productivity
they've also caused major disruptions
for many others today a high school
diploma no longer guarantees you a job
over the past 13 years about a third of
our manufacturing jobs have vanished
meanwhile the typical workers wages have
barely kept up with the rising costs of
everything else and all this was even
before a financial crisis and recession
that pounded the middle class even more
now we've made some tough decisions that
have turned our economy in a positive
direction over the past two years we've
created more than 2 million new jobs in
the private sector over the past 15
months alone including almost 250,000 in
manufacturing but we still have to
confront those underlying problems they
weren't caused overnight and we won't
solve them overnight but we will solve
and we're starting to solve them right
here in Pittsburgh and right here at
carnagie melt
and by the way that's why I ran for
president not just to get us back to
where we were I ran for president to get
us to where we need to be I have a
larger vision for America one where
working families feel secure feel like
they are moving forward and that they
know that their dreams are within reach
an America where our businesses lead the
world in new technologies like clean
energy where we work together Democrats
and Republicans to live within our means
to cut our deficit in debt but also to
invest in what our economy needs to grow
world-class education cutting edge
research and building the best
transportation and communications
infrastructure anywhere in the world
that's what it's going to take for us to
win the future and winning the future
begins with getting our economy moving
right now and that's why we're here
Carnegie Mellon is a great example of
what it means to move forward and its
founding no one would have imagined that
a trade school for the sons and
daughters of steel workers would one day
become the region's largest one of the
region's largest employers and a global
research university and yet innovations
led by your professors and your students
have created more than 300 companies and
9,000 jobs over the past 15 years
companies like Carnegie robotics but
more important than the ideas that
you've incubated or what those ideas
have become they've become products made
right here in America and many cases
sold all over the world and that's in
our blood that's who we are we are
inventors and we are makers and we are
doers if we want a robust growing
economy we need a robust growing
manufacturing sector and that's why we
told the auto industry two years ago
that if they were willing to adapt we'd
stand by them today they're profitable
they're creating jobs
and the repaying taxpayers ahead of
schedule that's why
that's why we've launched a partnership
to reach retrain workers with new skills
that's why we've invested in clean
energy manufacturing and new jobs
building wind turbines and solar panels
and advanced batteries we have not run
out of stuff to make it
we've just got to reinvigorate our
manufacturing sector so that it leads
the world the way it always has from
paper and steel and cars to new products
that we haven't even dreamed up yet
that's what how we're gonna strengthen
existing industries that's how we're
gonna spark new ones that's how we're
gonna create jobs grow the middle class
and secure our economic leadership and
this is why I asked my Council of
Advisors on science and technology what
we call PCAST
a while back to look at the state of
American manufacturing and the promise
of advanced manufacturing my concept of
advanced manufacturing is not
complicated it means how do we do things
better faster cheaper to design and
manufacture superior products that allow
us to compete all over the world and so
these very smart folks many of whom are
represented here wrote up a report which
is now up on the White House website but
we didn't want to just issue a report we
want to actually get something done so
we've launched an all-hands-on-deck
effort between our brightest academic
minds some of our boldest business
leaders and our most dedicated public
servants from science and technology
agencies all with one big goal and that
is a renaissance of American
manufacturing we're calling it amp EMP
the advanced manufacturing partnership
it's made up of some of the most
advanced engineering universities like
Carnegie Mellon Georgia Tech Stanford
Berkeley mission some of our most
innovative manufacturers from Johnson &
Johnson to Honeywell Stryker to
Allegheny technologies
I've asked Susan Hockfield the president
of MIT who was here there Susan
and Andrew Liveris the CEO of Dow
Chemical
to lead this partnership and to work
with my own advisers on science
technology and manufacturing throughout
our history our greatest breakthroughs
have often come from partnerships just
like this one
American innovation has always been
sparked by individual scientists and
entrepreneurs often at universities like
Carnegie Mellon or Georgia Tech or
Berkeley or Stanford but a lot of
companies don't invest in early ideas
because it won't pay off right away and
that's where government can step it
that's how we ended up with some of the
world changing innovations that fueled
our growth and prosperity and created
countless jobs the mobile phone the
internet GPS more than 150 drugs and
vaccines over the last 40 years was all
because we were able to in strategic
ways bring people together and make some
critical investments I'll take one
example the National Science Foundation
helped fund Stanford's digital library
project in the 1990s the idea was to
develop a universal digital library that
anybody could access so two enterprising
PhD students got excited about the
research that was being done at Stanford
this is funded by NSF so these two PhD
students they moved from campus to a
friend's garage and they launched this
company called Google and when the
private sector runs with the ball it
then leads to jobs building and selling
that is successful all over the world
this new partnership that we've created
we'll make sure tomorrow's breakthroughs
are American breakthroughs we're teaming
up to foster
we're teaming up to foster the kind of
collaborative R&D that resulted in those
same early discoveries and to create the
kind of innovation infrastructure
necessary to get ideas from the drawing
board to the manufacturing floor to the
market more rapidly all of which will
make our businesses more competitive and
create new high quality manufacturing
jobs now to help businesses operate at
less cost the energy department will
develop new manufacturing processes and
materials that use half as much energy
that will free up more money for
companies to hire new workers or buy new
equipment to help businesses discover
develop and deploy new materials twice
as fast we're launching what we call the
materials genome initiative the
invention of silicon circuits and
lithium-ion batteries made computers and
iPods and iPads possible but it took
years to get those technologies from the
drawing board to the marketplace we can
do it faster to help everyone from
factory workers to astronauts carry out
more complicated tasks NASA and other
agencies will support research into
next-generation robotics and I just met
with folks from a local company redzone
robotics who make robots that explore
water and sewer pipes and I have to say
this fascinating stuff when you've
watched the robots about this big it can
go through any sewer system it's it's
operated remotely by the municipal
worker it's got a camera attached so it
can film everything that is seeing it
then transmits the data that goes into a
citywide database and can enhance the
productivity of these workers by three
or fourfold and help the city make even
better decisions potentially this can
save cities millions in infrastructure
costs companies also training new
workers to operate the robots
and analysts to pour through the data
that's being collected to help smaller
manufacturers compete federal agencies
are working with private companies to
make powerful often unaffordable
modeling and simulation software easier
to access and I just saw an example a
few years ago Procter and Gamble teamed
up with the researchers at Los Alamos
National Labs to adapt software
developed for war to figure out what's
happening with nuclear particles and
they are using these simulators to
dramatically boost the performance of
diapers yes diapers
folks chuckle but those who have been
parents are always on the lookout for
indestructible military-grade diapers so
but but but here's what's remarkable
using this simulation software that was
developed at Los Alamos Procter & Gamble
has saved five hundred million dollars
half a billion dollars as a consequence
is simulated
now through the new partnership that
we're setting up Procter & Gamble is
offering its powerful fluid dynamics
simulator to smaller manufacturers and
it's doing it for free now this is not
just because Procter & Gamble wants to
do good it's also they've got thousands
of suppliers and they're thinking to
themselves if we can apply this
simulation of technology to our smaller
suppliers they're gonna be able to make
their products cheaper and better and
that in turn is gonna save us even more
money and it has a ripple effect
throughout the economy starting this
summer federal agencies will partner
with industries to boost manufacturing
in areas critical to our national
security I just saw an example backstage
the Defense Department scientists we we
call it DARPA the folks who brought us
stealth technology and by the way who
brought us the Internet
wanna see if it was possible to design
defense systems cheaper and faster so
they found a small company in Arizona
called Local Motors and they gave them a
test you have one month to design a new
combat support vehicle and you've got
three months to build their CEO Jay
Rogers is here today and as an ex-marine
who lost a couple of buddies in combat
understood the importance of increasing
the speed and adaptability and
flexibility of our manufacturing process
for vehicles that are used in theater so
local motors solicited design ideas on
their website chose the best out of 162
doesn't receive
built and brought this new vehicle here
ahead of schedule we just took a look at
not only could this change the way the
government uses your tax dollars because
think about it instead of having a a ten
year lead time to develop a a piece of
equipment with all kinds of changing
specs and a moving target if we were
able to collapse the pace at which that
manufacturing takes place that could
save taxpayers billions of dollars but
it also could get products out to
theater faster which could save lives
more quickly and could then be used to
transfer into the private sector more
rapidly which means we could get better
brought products and services that we
can sell an export around the world so
it's good for American companies it's
good for American jobs it's good for
taxpayers and it may save some lives in
places like Afghanistan for our soldiers
so that's what this is all about as
futuristic and let's face it as cool as
some of this stuff is as much as we are
planning for America's future this
partnership is about new cutting edge
ideas to create new jobs spark new
breakthroughs reinvigorate American
manufacturing today right now not
somewhere off in the future right now
it's about making sure our workers and
businesses have the skills and the tools
they need to compete better faster and
smarter than anybody else that's what
we're about we are America and we don't
just keep up with changing times we set
the pace for changing times we adapt and
we innovate we lead the way forward
now it's worth remembering there was a
time when steel was about as advanced as
manufacturing gut but when the namesake
of this university Andrew Carnegie an
immigrant by the way discovered new ways
to mass-produce Steel cheaply everything
changed just 20 years after founding his
company not only was it the largest most
profitable in the world America had
become the number one steel maker in the
world now imagine if America was first
to develop and mass-produce a new
treatment that kills cancer cells but
leaves healthy ones untouched or solar
cells you can brush onto a house for the
same cost as paint for flexible display
soldiers flexible displays that soldiers
can wear on their arms or a car that
drives itself imagine how many workers
and businesses and consumers would
prosper from those breakthroughs those
things aren't science fiction they're
real they're being developed and
deployed in labs and factories and on
test tracks right now they sprang from
the imagination of students and
scientists and entrepreneurs like all of
you and the purpose of this partnership
is to prove that the United States of
America has your back is going to be
supporting you because that's the kind
of adventurous pioneering spirit that we
need right now
that's the spirit that's given us the
tools and toughness to overcome every
obstacle and adapt to every circumstance
and if we remember that spirit if we
combine our creativity our innovation
and our optimism if we come together in
common cause as we've done so many times
before then we will thrive again we will
get to where we need to be and we will
make this century the American Century
just like the last Romans thank you very
much everybody god bless god bless the
United States of America